Florida has fired the scientists who
created their coronavirus dashboard that
tracks most states have something like
this it tracks daily cases and deaths
and other data and it is alleged that
she has been fired because she was
refusing to manipulate or I would call
it falsified data for political reasons
to make reopening seem like a more
reasonable thing to do now this
scientist name is Rebecca Jones she put
together these dashboards so that you
could go and see in real time where are
the outbreaks were the cases and deaths
she wasn't paid for this additional work
that she did she did it over a two-month
period and it is claimed that she was
told to censor or manipulate some data
and she refused to do it she was told to
manually change some data to help build
the case that reopening makes sense and
she refused to do it as she says and she
has now been fired now the interesting
thing about this coming out of Florida
is that I guess it was almost two weeks
ago I think it was on them not the last
Friday show but the previous one or
maybe the one before that time is all
blending together we had reports from a
few weeks ago that Florida was already
being accused of being dishonest about
their deaths and they were fielding
cause of death from these reporting
agencies this if true is North Korea
style propaganda too many deaths and
cases to reopen just make up different
numbers no problem whatsoever and again
I think it's important to underscore
that a lot of the headlines say that she
was refusing to manipulate data
she was refusing to falsify data
selectively releasing data or changes or
the manipulation this is falsification
it would be a form of fraud or
straight-up lies they are doing what
Trump and Republicans have been accusing
China of doing they are doing what Trump
and Republicans have been said it you
know maybe the death tolls are being
overstated well it looks like they are
being accused of doing the exact thing
although in the opposite direction to
make this seem less bad than it actually
is
now of
there are always details that are late
coming in was she straight-up fired or
forced to resign it's not clear she's
not communicating very much Rebecca
Jones's with with reporters over the
last 12 to 16 hours
what exactly was she asked to change
we're not really sure yet what was
observed was that over the last couple
weeks the demographic info about who is
getting infected and dying has been more
difficult to access as one example
reporters have been having more and more
trouble finding out how many cases and
deaths are coming from long-term care
and nursing home type facilities and
prisons which are big hot spots for
outbreaks of coronavirus at one point as
I told you the Florida State Government
prevented stopped medical examiners from
releasing death totals and also cause of
death and both of those things were
being done therefore for many many years
that was standard operating practice we
reported on that already and as usual we
still don't have transparency in terms
of the full scope of what they're hiding
or potentially falsifying we do need to
get more of the story from Rebecca Jones
she hopefully will be more communicative
with reporters in the upcoming period of
time now in terms of the numbers that
Florida has been releasing you know
earlier in the week I mentioned when you
look at some states that have been open
versus closed you see very similar
curves and we speculated this could be
because an open state might have a lot
of people isolating on their own whereas
a closed state might have a lot of
people ignoring the protocol it could be
that states are falsifying data we don't
really know in terms of the numbers that
Florida has released the case numbers
have been declining pretty modestly sort
of a similar pattern to states that have
been mostly shut down maybe a question
mark in light of this recent revelation
in terms of the deaths there's a strange
sort of herky-jerky up-and-down graph
for Florida deaths sometimes when you
see that it has to do with reporting
intervals where certain days of the week
you don't get full data and numbers are
pushed around potentially you know often
it's it's weekend's the numbers go down
it's not because if you
people are dying on the weekend it's
because the reporting is pushed to
Monday and Tuesday and tallied early in
the following week we're not really sure
in terms of testing levels Florida is
testing about 33,000 per million that
puts them at 27th in the United States
that's right about the middle Florida's
not particularly good or bad on testing
but again this is what they are
releasing and that's all we really know
we may know more soon as I say but we
may not and that's the whole point that
this is a story about the fact that we
are not being given information that is
absolutely necessary to figure out
what's going on in Florida to determine
are they ready to move to a phase one or
phase two reopening or whatever the case
may be
once again it's projection the right has
been saying that the left is falsifying
data for a while now no actual evidence
of that but now increasingly evidence
that it is the right that may be indeed
doing that and the very right-wing
Florida State Government of Governor Ron
de santis is at the at the center of
this at this point in time